[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
unser land steht vor einer schweren zeit
das gehört zur wahrheit in diesen tagen
und diese wahrheit muss ausgesprochen
werden
was der bundeskanzler der heute
ausspricht dürfte dem land schon länger
klar sein heute will die
regierungskoalition zeigen dass ihr klar
ist was jetzt geschehen muss guten abend
in allen nach 22 stunden verhandlungen
steht ein paket das die immensen
preissprünge abmildern soll das wuchtig
sein soll das zumindest finanziell erst
mal auch eine wucht ist 65 milliarden
euro schwer das sind rund 15 prozent des
gesamten bundeshaushalts fürs nächste
jahr es gibt auf jeden fall wuchtige
ankündigungen heute viele details
allerdings sind noch offen wir berichten
ausführlich in den nächsten 30 minuten
und beginnen jetzt mit andreas künast
und einem speziellen krisen tag des
kanzlers an dem er sich auch exklusiv im
zdf-sommerinterview den fragen meines
kollegen theo koll stellte
das ist doch der stolz rufen die
touristen und who und das ist der beste
moment dieses denkwürdigen tages an dem
olaf scholz eine warnung aussprechen
muss wie noch kein kanzler vor ihm dass
die lage nicht schwierig nicht sehr
schwierig sondern sehr sehr schwierig
ist in einer zeit in der das vertrauen
in den bundeskanzler auf einem
umfragetief punkt ist muss der
bundeskanzler um vertrauen bitten dann
will ich ihn gerne auch sagen dass ich
schon heißt dass es meine verantwortung
ist dafür zu sorgen dass wir
entschiedene handlungen machen und dass
wir sehr besonnen handeln und ich
ertrage dass das andere skeptisch
betrachten aber ich habe einen eid
geschworen und für diesen alt würde ich
arbeite tag und nacht beruhigen ja
beschönigen nein im zdf-sommerinterview
sagt scholz nur fast zu dass kein bürger
seine wohnung seine arbeit seine
existenz verlieren wird ja das kann ich
das wir
ganz klar zu sagen dass wir alles dafür
tun werden dass das nicht geschieht nur
fast dass es keinen blackout keinen
großen stromausfall geben wird wir haben
alles dafür getan dass es nicht dazu
kommt nur fast dass die sorge vor einem
land ohne strom also übertrieben ist ich
kann ihnen sagen dass alles was wir
getan haben dazu beiträgt dass das nach
allem menschlichen ermessen nicht
passiert reicht nach menschlichem
ermessen
ausreichen die 65 milliarden euro aus
auf die sich scholz ampel nach tage und
nächtelangem zank geeinigt hat die
opposition sagt erwartungsgemäß nein die
koalition gibt überhaupt keine antwort
darauf woher denn der strom für die
nächsten wochen und monate kommen soll
sie haben im grunde genommen diesen
angebotsschock den wir haben durch das
ausbleiben der russische gas überhaupt
nicht angesprochen geschweige denn
kompensiert
guten tag herr bundeskanzler
es gehört zum nicht so guten tag des
bundeskanzlers dass ausgerechnet heute
der ukrainische ministerpräsident zu
gast ist dennis schmidt wird scholz ganz
konkret um die lieferung von
leopard-2-panzern bitten scholz wird die
gemeinsame pressekonferenz absagen aus
termingründen
wir liefern sehr effiziente sehr
wirksame waffen immer abgestimmt mit
unseren franken und verbündeten und so
sind alle entscheidungen gut abgewogen
und das will ich ausdrücklich sagen dazu
stehe ich es wird keine deutschen
alleingänge
die bezeichnung zögerlich lässt scholz
nicht für sich gelten der kanzler nennt
sich entschieden aber besonnen ich bin
ganz klar sagen wir sind in einer zeit
in der viele sehr aufgeregt sind und ich
zähle nicht zu diesen und will das auch
nicht sein von den 270 tagen die olaf
scholz im amt ist war das einer der
schwierigen die sehr sehr schwierigen
kommen noch
es ist leicht den überblick zu verlieren
angesichts all der vorhaben änderungen
und kosten es geht um schwindlig machen
die summen und deshalb erklärt da der
anteil jetzt kompakt welche entlastungen
die koalition will und was sie mit dem
energiemarkt vorhat
energiepreis pauschale für alle jetzt
also auch für rentner innen zum ersten
dezember erhalten sie einmalig 300 euro
ebenso studierende und auszubildende
sie bekommen einmalig 200 euro der bund
verspricht zudem eine steuerliche
entlastung bei rentenbeiträgen
steuerzahlende sollen demnach ihre
beiträge ab dem kommenden jahr als
sonderausgaben voll absetzen können auch
sollen mehr menschen rund zwei millionen
bürger innen ab dem kommenden jahr
wohngeld erhalten heißt zum beispiel
einen zuschuss zur miete dazu kommt von
september bis dezember ein einmaliger
heizkostenzuschuss hat vier ab januar
bürgergeld soll auf ein regelsatz von
etwa 500 euro erhöht werden auch
familien werden stärker entlastet das
kindergeld wird zum ersten januar 2023
für das erste und zweite kind um 18 euro
angehoben und der kinderzuschlag für
familien mit niedrigem einkommen wird
noch mal erhöht auf 250 euro im monat
die sonderregelungen für das
kurzarbeitergeld
sollen über den 30 september hinaus
verlängert werden und es soll ein
nachfolgemodell für das neue euro ticket
geben 1,5 milliarden euro stellt der
bund zur verfügung wenn die länder
mindestens die gleiche summe darzulegen
ziel ein ticket zwischen 49 und 69 euro
im monat der strompreis soll durch einen
eingriff in den markt reguliert werden
für privathaushalte gilt dann eine
strompreis bremse für den basis
verbrauch finanziert werden soll das in
dem sogenannte zufalls gewinne der
unternehmen verhindert oder abgeschöpft
werden damit der strompreis nicht noch
weiter steigt soll die für anfang januar
geplante erhöhung des co2 preises um ein
jahr verschoben werden als ausgleich für
die gas umlage wird die umsatzsteuer auf
den gesamten gasverbrauch bis ende märz
2024 gesenkt von 19 auf 7 prozent
die drei entlastungs paket des bundes
belaufen sich auf insgesamt mehr als 95
milliarden euro
nicht kleckern sondern klotzen wir heute
das motto der regierungskoalition die
einen erkennen danach richtige und
wichtige schritte anderen fehlt
konkretes und das große problem bleibt
ja dann nimmt der staat aber milliarden
in die hand um hohe preise abzufedern
und viel von dem geld geht an die die
diese hohen preise überhaupt erst
kassieren oder wie es baron rothschild
weiland sagte ihr geld ist nicht weg es
ist nur woanders ich spreche gleich mit
dem bundesfinanzminister erst patricia
wiedemeier über die aktionen der
regierung und die reaktionen darauf
strahlend zufrieden zeigten sich die
grünen verhandler am frühen morgen auf
twitter schlaf werde überbewertet
schrieb kanzleramtschef wolfgang schmidt
es war eine lange verhandlungsrunde so
wie sie eigentlich nicht mehr
stattfinden soll doch wuchtige
entlastungspaket erfordern anscheinend
lange sitzungen nach 22 stunden gab es
dann die einigung auf das 65 milliarden
schwere paket und dies sei größer als
die ersten beiden zusammen es geht um 90
milliarden euro wenn man die beiden
ersten entlastungs paket
mit einbezieht das ist sehr viel was wir
bewegen es ist notwendig und es soll
dazu beitragen dass die bürgerinnen und
bürgern durch diese situation mit uns
gemeinsam durchgehen kann die ampel
liefert wir stehen den menschen mit
ihren nöten und ängsten
bei und wir werden unseren beitrag dazu
leisten dass wir gerade in diesen
schwierigen zeiten ein winter der
solidarität miteinander erlebt
65 weitere milliarden also der
finanzminister gibt sich zuversichtlich
dies ohne nachtragshaushalt finanzieren
zu können mit zusätzlichen einnahmen man
habe vorgesorgt die schuldenbremse werde
eingehalten
wir
stärken die menschen die unsere
solidarität brauchen und vergessen
diejenigen nicht auf deren schultern
dieses land steht nämlich die hart
arbeitende mitte helfen soll dabei nicht
mehr die lange geforderte über gewinn
steuer aus über gewinnen wird jetzt
zufalls gewinn und dieser soll bei
energie erzeugenden unternehmen
abgeschöpft werden wir haben deshalb
fest vor erinnerung dass wir die
marktordnung so ändern dass diese
zufalls gewinne nicht mehr anfallen oder
dass sie abgeschöpft werden die
reaktionen gemischt grundsätzlich falsch
findet kaum jemand die entlastungen aber
kritik gibt es dann doch beispiel neun
euro ticket es gibt eben keine schneller
anschlusslösung für neun euro ticket und
das bleibt ja auch völlig offen was es
am ende kosten wird der afg fehlen
perspektiven für die zukunft dessen
bonbons die man dem bürger hinwirft um
sie ruhigzustellen langfristig und auch
perspektivisch ist nichts vorhanden um
das problem der energieknappheit auch
der energiekosten zu lösen weiteres
beispiel bürgergeld ja wir haben den
umstand dass sieben millionen menschen
die im grundsicherung leben und die
wirklich nicht mehr wissen wie sie ans
monatsende kommen sollen finanziell dass
die völlig leer ausgeben bis jahresende
und das dann auch zum
1.1.2013 und 20 lediglich eine erhöhung
der regelsätze um 50 euro stattfinden
soll dass es gerade mal
inflationsausgleich dass er seit tropfen
auf den heißen stein
heftige kritik an den heutigen
beschlüssen kam auch von umweltschützern
die aussetzung der co2 preisanhebung sei
das falsche signal beim thema
klimaschutz das falsche signal das von
dieser regierung ausging
christian lindner ist der
bundesfinanzminister guten abend herr
lindner also einen schönen guten abend
sie hatten gesagt in diesem jahr seien
maximal neun milliarden spielraum drin
jetzt 165 milliarden geworden die das
alles den staat kostet da haben sie
offenbar plötzlich noch eine menge geld
gefunden nein im bundeshaushalt werden
wir bei etwa acht milliarden euro sein
die anderen maßnahmen beziehen sich ja
auf bund und länder und auf die jahre
2022 2023 wir sind also genau in dem
plan den ich als zielkorridor schon habe
anmelden können insgesamt 32 milliarden
finanzmehrbedarf kommt dabei raus haben
sie errechnet da sind wir immer noch
nicht bei den 65 milliarden wo sondern
der rest herkommen aber sie stellen sehr
spezielle fragen die ich auch gerne
beantworte die 32 milliarden das sind
die mittel aus dem bundeshaushalt
einerseits mittel aus diesem jahr
2022 wir wirtschaften ja sehr sorgfältig
überlegen genau welche ausgabe können
wir machen deshalb ist es möglich in
diesem jahr noch für die rentnerinnen
und rentner eine einmalzahlung zu
finanzieren aus dem haushalt 300 euro
für das nächste jahr 2023 habe ich
bereits etwas über neun milliarden euro
eingeplant zum beispiel für die kalte
progression also die bekämpfung
automatische steuererhöhungen in der
arbeitenden mitte das wurde ja gott sei
dank jetzt auch von spd und grünen
bestätigt dass dieses vorhaben kommt und
darüber hinaus erlaubt uns die
entwicklung der einnahmen und so wie wir
den haushalt aufgestellt haben dass wir
die mittel die auf den bund zukommen
finanzieren können die anderen mittel
sind außerhalb des bundeshaushaltes die
strompreis bremse und der beitrag von
ländern und gemeinden interessant dass
sie jetzt ganz am ende dann die
strompreis bremse nennen die alleine
bringt ja kein geld in die staatskasse
rein sondern nur wenn man sie verknüpft
mit einer ja das hieß mal
gewinn steuer da waren sie strikt
dagegen jetzt heißt es abschaffen von
zufalls gewinnen aber dabei heller ist
ja überhaupt nicht klar ob das
tatsächlich klappt sie werden sich
erinnern an ihren kollegen robert habeck
bei der gasanlage da steckt der teufel
im detail sie rechnen also mit
milliarden einnahmen die sie im moment
gar nicht haben ja die sache liegt etwas
anders herr sie wird da geht es gar
nicht um eine über gewinn steuer sie
haben das wort gerade verwendet sondern
der vergleich ist die eeg umlage das
erkennen die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer von ihrer stromrechnung bis
zur mitte dieses jahres da wurde immer
ausgewiesen eeg-umlage geld das die
menschen gezahlt haben an subventionen
zum beispiel für windkraft und
solarenergie jetzt ist die lage anders
jetzt werden die produzenten von
windstrom solarstrom kohlestrom
atomstrom so bezahlt als hätten sie
teures gas eingekaufter entstehen
zufalls gewinne aufgrund der von der
politik gemachten regeln und genau wie
abschöpfen der bundeskanzler hat vorhin
im zdf-sommerinterview gesagt ob man es
jetzt über gewinn oder zufalls gewinn
nennt ist eigentlich egal am ende geht
es darum dass diese unternehmen das
nicht behalten dürfen aber lassen sie es
mich doch erklären ja sie hat sie haben
sie eigentlich finde ich schon sehr klar
erklärt die frage ist jetzt nur wie viel
wird denn daraus entstehen und
funktioniert das alles auch überhaupt so
wie sie sich das jetzt mal vorgestellt
haben am grünen tisch also wir haben ja
ein vorbild wie ich gerade erläutert
habe nämlich die eeg-umlage wo an diese
und andere unternehmen geld gegeben
wurde und wir kehren jetzt das
vorzeichen um und im gleichen verfahren
wird jetzt geld
auf ein konto geholt geht nicht in
staatshaushalt es ist keine steuer und
es ist auch nicht für allgemeine zwecke
einsetzbar
es wird eine erlös bremse geschaffen und
das geld wird eingesetzt um einen
grundbedarf an strom für die bürgerinnen
und bürger und eine entlastung für die
betriebe zu organisieren das wird
gelingen wo ist denn dieser basis deckel
dann ganz genau wo ist dieser basispreis
und wieviel basis verbrauch wenn man so
will beim strom darf denn dann jeder
haben das definieren jetzt die
zuständigen behörden die liegen in der
zuständigkeit meines kollegen robert
habeck und daraus ein erprobtes
verfahren ist bin ich mir sicher dass
wir sehr schnell ergebnisse haben ich
unterstütze das der preis deckel beim
gas da wird jetzt erst mal das ist ja
dass das sehr sehr wichtige thema das
sehr drängende thema das im mittelpunkt
steht dann wird jetzt erstmal eine
kommission eingesetzt warum ausgerechnet
da so schwammig er ist nicht schwammig
sondern ist ein völlig anderer
sachverhalt beim strom haben wir die
situation dass wir an dass wir
marktregeln haben die zufalls gewinne
erzeugen die nichts zu tun haben mit
investitionen risiko der innovation die
von der politik mit einem rendite
autopiloten soll ich das neulich in der
kabinettsklausur in meseberg genannt die
da entstehen das kann man nicht
tolerieren beim gas handelt es sich um
weltmarktpreise und knappheiten da liegt
die sache komplizierter und da wirken
wir jetzt auf europäischer ebene an
lösungen mit ihm an einen weltmarkt
einzugreifen wo es um knappheiten geht
ist anders als politisch gemachte markt
regeln anzupassen und zu korrigieren mit
dem was wir heute als vorhaben skizziert
haben beschlossen haben glauben sie dass
sie damit denen den wind aus den segeln
nehmen können die auf die straße gehen
wollen in deutschland
wir sind vor schwierigen zeiten sie war
das ist völlig klar dass dass das so ist
wir können das in unserer macht stehende
tun um die haushalte die menschen die
familien zu unterstützen die menschen
die sorgen haben vor leeren kühlschrank
und kalter wohnung wir können die
betriebe unterstützen beim strompreis
entlassen aber es bleiben harte zeiten
und dennoch die menschen die besonders
bedroht sind von sozialen härten da
gibt's wohngeld bürgergeld
kinderzuschlag und ich sorge mich auch
um die breite mitte der gesellschaft
herr sievers das sind die leute 40
50.000 euro verdienst als familie die
bekommen wenig sozialleistungen keine
sozialleistungen zahlen die hohen preise
und ich bin froh dass es gelungen ist
die die steuererhöhungen der kalten
progression es war ja sehr umstritten in
den medien von spd und grünen dass das
in diesem paket drin ist die menschen
die arbeiten die keine sozialleistungen
bekommen die werden zumindest bei der
steuer nicht weiter and nicht weiter
belastet für die organisierende auch
entlastung das hält die gesellschaft
zusammen sagt der bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner ich danke ihnen für
das gespräch lindner ich danke ihnen
herr sievers
und das gespräch habe aus termingründen
vor einer stunde aufgezeichnet so was
heute noch wichtig war dass jetzt bei
dir hanna deutschland hat der ukraine
weitere hilfen in höhe von 200 millionen
euro zugesagt bei dem gespräch von
bundesentwicklungsministerin schulze und
dem ukrainischen ministerpräsidenten
schneefall ging es um den wiederaufbau
des landes und den akuten
unterstützungsbedarf schulze erklärte
dass die neuen hilfen vor allem
binnenflüchtlingen zugute kommen sollen
israels präsident herzog ist heute zu
einem dreitägigen staatsbesuch in
deutschland eingetroffen und wurde von
bundespräsident steinmeier mit
militärischen ehren im schloss bellevue
empfangen
bei einer pressekonferenz würdigten
beide die einigung über entschädigungen
für die hinterbliebenen des olympia
attentats
1972 dass diese allerdings erst kurz vor
dem morgigen 50 jahrestag erzielt worden
sei bezeichnete steinmeier als regimes
mit blick auf den fachkräftemangel in
deutschland will bundesarbeitsminister
heidi zuwanderung von ausländischen
arbeitskräften erleichtern und hat eine
sogenannte chancen karte mit einem
punktesystem angekündigt jedes jahr
solle dem bedarf entsprechend ein
kontingent festgelegt werden wie viele
menschen mit der karte nach deutschland
kommen dürfen erklärte heil der bild am
sonntag
im herbst werde die ampel koalition ein
neues einwanderungsgesetz vorlegen
der ehemalige us-präsident trump hat
seinen nachfolger joe biden bei einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung als staatsfeind
bezeichnet die gefahr für die demokratie
gehe von der radikalen linken aus nicht
von der rechten sagte trump auch als
reaktion auf eine rede von joe biden der
am freitag trump scharf angegriffen
hatte
es war der erste öffentliche auftritt
trumps seit den durchsuchungen des fbi
in seinem wohnsitz in den usa finden im
november kongresswahlen statt
russlands präsident führt einen krieg
gegen die ukraine seine attacken aber
sind nicht nur militärisch und nicht nur
auf die ukraine beschränkt längst tobt
auch ein wirtschaftskrieg gegen die die
an russischem gas hängen und das sind ja
in besonderer weise wir hier in
deutschland und dazu kommt jetzt noch
eine kampagne mit falschinformationen
die alles in den schatten stellt was
einschlägige experten bislang erlebt
haben ziel ist die gesellschaft zu
verunsichern die fundamente der
demokratie ins wanken zu bringen mittel
sind perfide gemachte fälschungen und
halbwahrheiten auf der einen seite und
haarsträubende lügen auf der anderen
motto irgendwas bleibt immer hängen
deutschland und europa tun sich sehr
schwer damit darauf zu reagieren das
aber könnte sich jetzt ändern wie
florian neumann zeigt
das ist die geschichte eines krieges
ohne waffen aber mit echter wirkungen
geführt auf einer parkbank in brüssel
aus einem home office in dresden oder
über ein handy in süddeutschland drei
von tausenden die sich in diesen wochen
zusammengefunden haben unter den
scherzhaften label nach north atlantic
fälle organisation die nordatlantik
kumpel die symbole ein japanischer und
ihre selbst gewählte aufgabe russische
fake news zu kontern mit humor und
echten argumenten und mittlerweile mit
einigem erfolg
als der krieg begann fand ich es wichtig
etwas zu tun ich kann nicht militärisch
kämpfen aber ich kann das informationen
bekämpfen
weiters information ich möchte ganz ins
bett gehen können und sagen können ich
habe versucht was dagegen zu tun und sei
es nur durch aufklärung und bekämpfung
von propaganda die merken dass die stört
das und ist auch so dass die propaganda
einfach nicht mehr diesen zugriff hat
den sie unkommentiert haben können
beispiel dieser russische botschafter in
wien wer auf einen tweet so viel
gegenwind bekam dass er sich kurzzeitig
ganz aus dem netz zurückzog
gestartet als gag wurde aus nah vor eine
kleine massenbewegung sogar der
ukrainische verteidigungsminister
bedanken sich dieser tage passend mit
hund als profilbild weil er verstanden
hat wie wichtig dieses schlachtfeld ist
sagt der politikwissenschaftler tobias
fehler der regelmäßig bundeswehrsoldaten
im umgang mit sozialen medien trainieren
wir erleben immer kleine krieg einen
kampf um deutungshoheit um wahrheit im
digitalen raum wenn sich dort eben
russischen archive durchsetzen dann kann
es eben sein dass auch die politik sich
genötigt sieht eben die unterstützung
der keine zurückzufahren
derjenige der wahrheit bestimmt sei es
durch durch irgendwie fakten oder
propaganda der hat wade macht und wie
propaganda auf prorussisch funktioniert
enthüllt diese woche das nachrichten
portal t-online gefälschte nachrichten
seiten massenhaft verbreitet darin lügen
wie der angebliche befehl des
ukrainischen präsidenten sie lenski
zivilisten zu töten lügen den der westen
bisher wenig entgegenzusetzen hatte
außer faktenchecks die selten dieselben
leute erreichen und jetzt die nach wo
die russische propaganda nicht einfach
stehen lassen will
früher konnten russische account auf
twitter als laute minderheit der viel
raum einnehmen hatten eine große wirkung
ich glaube dass sie nun etwas kleiner
geworden ist
es ist die geschichte eines krieges im
netz der am ende nicht im netz bleibt um
dabei zu sein spenden sie geld auch für
echte waffen für die ukraine
und den sportlichen teil dieses sonntags
dazu kommen wir jetzt und den hast du im
blick und da starten wir mit einem
weiteren erfolg des deutschen teams bei
der basketball-em aber einem denkbar
knappen beim spiel gegen litauen haben
ist die deutschen richtig spannend
gemacht und siegten erst nach zweifacher
verlängerung mit 109 zu 107 nach fast
zweieinhalb stunden ende dieses epische
duell das auf deutscher seite maßgeblich
von den beiden nba spieler nenne
schröder und franz wagner geprägt wird
die zusammen mehr als die hälfte der
punkte erzielen ein klares zeichen für
den tollen teamgeist ist es aber dass
die partie in köln von dem berliner
modolo mit 23 jahren in der zweiten
verlängerung entschieden wird
deutschland damit in der endrunde aber
noch unter vorbehalt denn litauen hat
wegen eines formalen
schiedsrichterfehler protest eingelegt
in der fußball bundesliga gab es heute
zwei partien der fc augsburg verlor
gegen hertha bsc berlin mit 0 2 und am
abend spielten borussia mönchengladbach
und mainz 05 gegen einander endstand 0
zu 1 formel 1 weltmeister max verstappen
hat den großen preis der niederlande
gewonnen der red bull pilot siegte wie
im vorjahr bei seinem heimrennen in
zandvoort vor george russell im mercedes
und schale claire im ferrari
wieder brennt es am brocken im harz nach
drei wochen ist ein neuer brand
ausgebrochen der landkreis hat den
katastrophenfall ausgerufen
150 hektar stehen mittlerweile in
flammen das feuer frisst sich immer
schneller durch den nationalpark die
lage ist nicht unter kontrolle die
einsatzkräfte gehen davon aus dass die
löscharbeiten mehrere tage dauern werden
flugzeuge aus italien österreich und der
schweiz sollen sie unterstützen
eine ziemlich turbulente woche geht zu
ende immer gut zu wissen worauf wir uns
kommende woche einstellen sollten hier
ist der heute journal ausblick von laura
panik
[Musik]
am montag jährt sich das attentat auf
die olympischen spiele zum fünfzigsten
mal in erinnerung an den 15 september
1972 werden in münchen und
fürstenfeldbruck gedenkfeier stattfinden
daran wird auch der israelische
präsident herzog teilnehmen er hatte
zugesagt nachdem der streit um die
entschädigungszahlungen für die
hinterbliebenen beigelegt worden war
in berlin wird am mittwoch der
bundestags ausschuss für klimaschutz und
energie zu einer sondersitzung
zusammenkommen das 34 köpfige gremium
wird sich zu themen wie energiewende
fragen des klimaschutzes und über
weitere möglichkeiten der energie
einsparungen beraten
ein neues treffen im sogenannten
rammstein format steht für den
donnerstag auf der agenda
us-verteidigungsminister osten lag
verteidigungsminister und hochrangige
militärs der verbündeten staaten auf die
airforce base nach ramstein ein
gemeinsam will man über weitere
unterstützung für die ukraine sprechen
am samstag werden die stars und
sternchen ein letztes mal für dieses
jahr über den roten teppich in venedig
laufen das älteste filmfestival der welt
bittet zum 79 mal an den lido die
filmfestspiele eröffnet hatte der
netflix film white noise er ist einer
von 23 filmen die um den begehrten
hauptpreis
den goldenen löwen für den besten film
konkurrieren
und jetzt noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten in den nächsten tagen
morgen ist es im norden und osten wolkig
schauer bleiben aber die ausnahme
sonst gibt es viel sonne erst am abend
im äußersten südwesten gewitter 21 grad
werden es an der ostsee 32 grad am rhein
am dienstag gibt es viele schauer und
gewitter im südwesten mit unwettergefahr
durch starkregen auch danach wird es oft
sehr nass und deutlich kühler am
donnerstag nur noch 18 bis 24 grad
und das war unsere welt im heute journal
an diesem ersten septembersonntag danke
dass sie dabei waren ab morgen freuen
sich hier marietta slomka und heinz wolf
auf sie und die nächsten nachrichten
gibt es hier gegen 0.30 heute express
mit anfang schicken von uns allen hier
im journal thiemann sie einen angenehmen
abend und tschüss
[Musik]